une robe verte et une coiffe blanche
reconnaissable revoilà bécassine la
bigoudène est remise au goût du jour le
versailles et bruno podalydès créé sa
nounou 2018 toujours naïve et empoté
c'est une idée drôle la seconde relie
démunis des drôles bécassine est là elle
a quelque chose de
je n'occulte ajustements
on lui reproche beaucoup de choses à
cette bécassine alors c'est une jeune
femme de papier très attachant j'ai
appris à la découvrir en écrivant le
film et je
fois drôle et émouvante c'est un bon
cocktail web au sein des cas sinon
bonjour madeleine bonjour mademoiselle
chatel on a vu passer trois nourrices en
un mois alors attention mademoiselle b
casting c'est l'heure du biberon
[Musique]
le réalisateur du mystère de la chambre
jaune et le parfum de la dame en noir
signe ici son huitième long métrage où
il mélange gags originaux et nouvelle
invention avec au casting karin viard
denis podalydès
emeline bayart j'avais vu que cet acte
et c'était extraordinaire et méconnus
comme un peu comme mega sine et du coup
j'ai en superposant les sur le visage
des mines les dessins de bécassine j'ai
vu un film possible
j'ai écrit en pensant à elle
le film a suscité la colère d'un
mouvement indépendantiste breton mais
cette deuxième adaptation est à
découvrir dans les salles dès ce
mercredi 20 juin mais passé madame la
marquise est urgent je reviens monsieur
reste à claques hausse madame la
marquise prince akoulov à l'appareil